a audi a todos a inicialmente
agradecendo o convite de estar aqui
compartilhando a idéia há muito está
entre mariana
mesmo não sendo aqui eu tenho um projeto
aqui sobre o qual eu vou responder à
onda revital foi adotado com a
comunidade do comportamento antes de
iniciá se sobre o estilo da nossa
vestimenta conta hoje é encontrar
caminhos para responder a esses
questionamentos
a gente tá vendo aqui a insistente forma
sistemática com que mostra se é esse
caminho que vai recorre a conexão para
adicionar pessoas né e entendimento e
iraty é quais são essas oportunidades
ele vai detectar e dessa forma ele
traduzem projeto então sejam projetos de
produto gráfico ambientes moda
especificamente sobre o qual eu vim
falar hoje né
é eu achei interessante primeiro a gente
é contextualizar essas papel do design
porque ao longo da minha fala eu vou é
descrever como que o design contribuiu
como transformador social nesse projeto
realizado aqui em mariana
outro ponto que é interessante a gente
iniciar falando sobre a sustentabilidade
já que eu levantei proac um
questionamento sobre o ciclo de vida das
nossas roupas
eu tô falando de sustentabilidade né no
universo da da moda do vestuário e é
interessante a gente é falar um
pouquinho da sustentabilidade nesses
quatro pilares né que seria o pilar
ambiental social econômico e cultural
aqui eu estou colocando os quatro
pilares citados por rick na saks né que
ele tem outros pilares mas foram esses
aqui que foram o que o projeto abarcou
né que conseguiu é contemplar durante
esse projeto realizado com as
bordadeiras estão falando no aspecto
ambiental
eu acho que ele foi o ponto de partida
porque a ele o que nos instiga muito é
que a cadeia produtiva de moda é muito
geradora de resíduos né então se a gente
for olhar aqui a cadeia produtiva de
moda da indústria
do vestuário ela produz por ano 175 mil
toneladas de resíduos e desses 175 mil
apenas 36 mil toneladas e geram novos
produtos novas roupas e barbantes e o
restante é descartado em aterros
sanitário
então é esse resíduo que vai proteger
sanitário ele na verdade ele é um jeito
né porque o plano nacional de
gerenciamento de resíduos ele classifica
a párea de têxtil mec é que a sobra de
tecido das confecções
ele classifica como resíduo porque ele é
homogêneo limpo e 100% reciclável e no
brasil a gente já tem equipamentos para
fazer a reciclagem do tecido vira pra eu
que virem novo fio
então é infelizmente o nosso projeto
constatou é um grande descarte um aterro
sanitário o lixo têxtil ele vai junto
com o lixo comum é ea gente constatou
isso porque o nosso projeto ele foi
feito no inverno horizonte never
horizonte é um pólo de confecção têxtil
na ele tem dois pólos no bairro prado e
no barro preto e com isso ele compõe
cerca de 1.250 confecções na indústria
de confecção e aí a gente fez um
mapeamento de como eram esse resíduo é o
tipo de resíduo a tipo de tecido e tal e
aí como que foi dando seqüência ao
projeto agente utilizou essa sobra de
tecido eram sobras tanto das do processo
produtivo em si
quantos obras de coleções normalmente
uma empresa de moda ela é segundo a
associação brasileira de indústria
têxtil ela descarta cerca de 20 a 30%
dos da sua matéria prima é que ela
comprou para uma coleção ela descarta
cerca de 20 a 30 por cento e isso acaba
ficando lá nas prateleiras
é e leva ano de tal então a gente também
pegou esse tipo de resíduo
e aí a gente agora falando um pouquinho
sobre o projeto então com esse material
é em forma de tecidos aviamentos a gente
fez um projeto de extensão então que foi
o projeto projeto de extensão da
universidade é da escola de design da
universidade o ing que foi realizado com
as bordadeiras aqui de mariana do
movimento renovador que estão felizmente
dessa vez elas estão presentes aqui né
pra assistir e que todos podem as
velozes a exposição e dos produtos delas
e houve uma troca muito grande de
conhecimento entre universidade alunos e
comunidade é o projeto é interessante
porque ele ele é contemplou uma um
protagonismo do grupo que essa eu acho
que esse era o ponto fulcral assim do
projeto em que elas conseguissem fazer
uma criação com a gente de forma que o
produto tivesse uma identidade
com isso a gente teve uma contemplação
no pelo quesito ambiental
quando a gente fala no cultural no sócio
é sócio econômico antes de falar do
cultural é a gente tem o projeto nem ele
contemplou o quesito sócio cultural
porque ele trouxe um uma autonomia para
o grupo o quanto a gente procurou a
comunidade de aqui de mariana é era
muito recente ainda nem o evento da
barreira do fundão é do rompimento e só
que a gente veio com aquela aquele
sentimento de preocupação como e lidar
com o assunto mas a gente encontrou um
grupo muito fortalecido um grupo muito
decidido de mulheres muitos unidas que
sabiam o que queriam e disparou
essa realmente é trabalhar de forma
colaborativa é criando mesmo né então é
isso foi uma coisa que ajudou muito
então é nos permitiu à equipe do projeto
que a gente conseguisse é fazer usar
ferramentas metodologias design que uma
vez que o que o projeto acabasse o grupo
caminhasse de forma autônoma e com isso
a gente criou uma marca que foi a das
marias né
a gente criou identidade visual
identidade de marca é planilhas de custo
então eu acho que isso fortaleceu e hoje
elas estão caminhando no quesito é
cultural eu acho que foi um dos pontos
mais desafiadores do projeto porque
quando a gente chegou em mariana
a gente fez é aquela é coisa da gente
participar é chegar com o olhar do
estrangeiro respeitando a identidade da
do local os saberes né tradicionais
então isso já era um ponto a ser
respeitado desde o início assim então a
gente fez é uma uma procurou entender a
relação que a comunidade tinha com esse
território é de mariana pode passar aqui
a gente tem por exemplo que o manzini
nos fala que é deve ser feito uma
valorização dessa estreita relação entre
a existência ea qualidade de um
território das comunidades que nele
vivem como que a gente tentou traduzir
isso para o projeto agente utilizou
ferramentas de design que nos permite
sem entender o que o que representava a
cidade de mariana pra pra cada uma
integrante do grupo
a gente tinha integrante de fora tinha
integrante que nasceu aqui na cidade e
elas nos contaram em forma de vídeo em
forma de escrita
de desenhos né fazendo desenhos fazendo
escritas aqui a gente tem uma das
ferramentas de design que é um mapa de
empatia no qual elas é nos colocam que
elas sentem como elas vêm à cidade isso
gerou esboços né desenhos que foram na
verdade depois é transcritos nos traços
dos bordados das carteiras que vocês
verão e podem ver lá fora que vai ser
passado aqui é e aí e se esse é essa
transcrição ela nos ajudou a dar uma
identidade local
é mais uma vez eu queria deixar aqui um
questionamento também que é assim eu não
sei quem é da cidade também quem é de
fora quem veio para o evento aqui de
fora é se vocês percorreram o comércio a
cidade se viram produtos com identidade
local de mariana s são produtos que você
bate os olhos e ver a isso realmente
representa a identidade é nós quando
viemos para o projeto a gente via essa é
uma carência muito grande de produtos
que refletisse a identidade local e elas
também nos questionavam isso que achavam
que as feiras dos produtos aqui não
traziam uma identidade local então a 1
ponto maior
o hoje que o que foi mais desafiador foi
justamente isso como trabalhar essa
identidade e aí a gente utilizou as
ferramentas a gente também tem o mapa
mental que foi feito é de sobre o que
ela representava o projeto como o
projeto iria caminhar quais as suas
inter relações que existiam é com a casa
da cultura que é onde a gente realizou o
projeto
a partir dessas é ferramentas a gente
conseguiu criar um produto com
identidade local
um produto que é como que a gente ia
fazer a identificação de origem desse
produto e aí veio a idéia da gente fazer
um projeto gráfico que tivesse uma
identidade visual criando uma
a criação da marca das marias ela teve
uma foi baseado na nome da cidade de
mariana na união do grupo nexxera um
grupo se reunia todas as semanas na casa
da cultura e com isso a gente criou
identidade visual mas a gente sentiu que
o grupo foi criando tarefas e se
fortalecendo então se dividiram em
costura que embora ainda expresse sua
gente que achou a alegria a necessidade
de identificar no produto é sua origem
então com isso a gente fez as tags
identificando que engordou quem costurou
é justamente também com a intenção de
fortalecer a identificação de origem e
eu volto naquele questionamento da gente
que a gente deve se fazer de onde vem a
matéria prima né é a matéria falando de
matéria prima que queria falar uma coisa
que eu deixei de falar nisso que foi é
quando a gente pegou os resíduos né
voltando à questão ambiental a gente
trabalhou a a reutilização né porque
você pode reciclar ou reutilizar
nós trabalhamos aqui a reutilização
desses tecidos utilizando a técnica do
abc site em que é uma técnica que
consiste em você reutilizar gerando um
novo produto com maior valor agregado e
sem com o mínimo de consumo de energia
você não gerou uma nova matéria prima
você pegou uma matéria que existia e
gerou um produto foi interessante porque
o projeto ele plantou uma semente no
grupo e aí de repente quando eu vi nas
22 três visitas e lá pela terceira
visita a gente já se deparou com essa
sacos de doação da doação ações de dos
uniformes da vale do rio doce e que
vocês podem ver lá fora elas estão
fazendo com as calças dos uniformes com
as camisas gerando ecobags né e
carteiras
então é foi um despertar também para
essa questão da sustentabilidade pode
passar é e aí a identidade local foi
feito obviamente
na forma de botões corte a laser e foi
realizado na universidade ong em belo
horizonte ea gente vai ver um vídeo
agora que mostra um pouco do dos
produtos dessa relação não é que a gente
tem com o o projeto make inicial mas
mostrando o produto ea relação é grupo
com os próprios produtos e aí no vídeo a
gente consegue ver um pouco da da
presença de cada um mané que costurou
[Música]
ninguém
bom então é a partir daqui a gente pode
ver um pouco de medo dos produtos que
foram criados e hoje passou um ano do
projeto então é e foi bom porque o meu
retorno eu consegui ver que o grupo está
caminhando nenhum movimento renovador
continua forte estão gerando novos
produtos e trabalhando muito ainda essa
questão da sustentabilidade é o que fica
claro aqui né com esse projeto é que
quando é a transformação social ela
nunca vem sozinha nela ela vem junto é
da transformação ambiental cultural para
que ela tenha um resultado efetivo é
aqui a gente fecha como eu falei
inicialmente do design é interessante a
gente é ver aqui qual o como que o
design é um vetor né trânsito de
transformação social é mas que ele acaba
que ele tem que ter um olhar para o
entorno tanto ambiental quanto cultural
o mais interessante é que eu acho que é
a questão que se fala muito da
sustentabilidade social ambiental é mais
o cultural aqui nesse ponto é caso de
mariana ele foi muito forte e bush ter
essa necessidade de ter um produto com
identidade local então assim foi um
ponto a ser trabalhado eu acho que tá
sendo é conseguido ea questão do
material não é que foi a questão do
reaproveitamento é que eu acho que fica
aqui por isso eu levantei o
questionamento inicial e volta agora
aqui né pra gente fechar é do quanto é
importante a gente sabendo o ciclo de
vida de quanto é de um produto que o
consumo desde o plantio do algodão
ainda das fibras naturais sejam elas
quais forem
até o seu descarte né pra aonde esse é a
gente fala muito do do berço ao berço
então assim hoje em dia a gente pensar
nesse produto de onde ele veio para onde
ele vai
então acho que a gente é o projeto ele
nos dá e talvez não um caminho porque um
caminho que solucionem eu acho que é
muita pretensão porque a gente está
dentro do âmbito muito maior então é
isso
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]